do you ever see kids dressed up as y'all
like from I get very creeped out when I
see kids as like my character from get
out watching that I loved it I was like
whoa yeah you don't want to see a 9 year
old in a turtleneck okay I speaking
Halloween I heard that you had like a
scary ghost story I do I do I just got
back from shooting a little movie in
Mexico and we went to this very small
town outside of Mexico City called
Cuernavaca and we stayed in this very
very old Hacienda it's like built in the
1500s and we rented out the whole place
so there were no other guests staying
there and I had a night shoot so I was
walking around the Hacienda by myself
like outside in the balcony trying his
service I feel somebody like touch my
face and I freaked out and I run back to
my hotel room and I'm like leave me
alone leave me alone what just happens
you know and then as I'm in the hotel
room it's thundering and lightning and
the power goes out sure so I scream at
the top of my lungs I go I can't take
this anymore I'm like leave me alone I
love it here I'm not mad like why are
you mad at me and I go down to the lobby
after the power comes on he's like oh so
that was Hernan Cortes I said excuse me
like you know that one was like oh
that's he's apparently the founder of
Mexico and he haunts that Hacienda and
that has happened to people before I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this